the legend of the flying lambos scam
known as bitcloud continues ladies and
gentlemen and we're talking about it
today i've been doing some deep digging
into the blockchain and i found out who
holds all the risk
surprise it's you it's not the founders
uh it's not tyler or cameron winkle
twins whatever their names are it's you
i hope you're happy to know that and it
gets
worse there's some sketchy shenanigans
that i think you should know about if
you
ever want to consider investing in this
scam look i think it's a good idea
a decentralized twitter or something
that's basically what it is like a poor
man's twitter right now it's just the
founders are greedy and trying to
extract the maximum
amount of money from you in the most
kind of a
cynical way possible let's talk about it
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million studio i'm your host coffee
zilla
and today like i said we're doing some
deep diving into the blockchain i never
thought it'd be a blockchain explorer
but here we are
bitcloud guys you know it do you love it
i don't know a lot of people like the
idea as i was saying earlier
it's supposed to be a decentralized
twitter
that's what it bills itself as if you
check it out the front page
it looks very aspirational it calls
itself the crypto
social network but there are some
incredibly important details
that have been left out conveniently of
the white paper
that i'd like to tell you about today
now last time on our last video a big
cloud the worst game i've seen in a
while
we talked about how they were stealing
creators identity
stealing their right to publicity to get
some free money and they've so far
accumulated about 200 million dollars in
bitcoin
no i did not stutter 200 million dollars
and it's being
seen and valued at one billion dollars
and i'm just looking at this like
it's like a bad movie right it's like if
it's this bad movie and all your friends
are like trying to pretend it's good
it's like
oh that's bad except instead of like
your friends pretending the movie's good
because
you know whatever maybe they're hyped up
about it it's like the friends are
pretending it's good because they got
paid in advance to
be incentivized that is good that's
what's happening all these guys that you
think are
fans of bid cloud have been prepaid
to join in that's what we're talking
about today see there's something called
the genesis block we're going to talk
about today this is
the pre mind this is what happens before
you ever get access to it before i ever
get access
uh for investors and founders they kind
of
give a little money off to the side this
is uh not totally
atypical a little bit frowned upon to
take too much stuff
because if you take a huge chunk of your
currency up front
this is seen as a short-sighted move to
extract
maximum amounts of money now previously
diamond hands the creator of bitcloud
said there was a pre-mine of
2 million bitcoin out of a total supply
of something like
21 million bitcoin although he said
because it doubles
every uh ever every million big bit
clout
it's going to be a max of 19 million
bits bit cloud so there's a pre-mine of
2 million that sounds reasonable right
it's like less a little over 10 percent
for founders and investors well turns
out
that wasn't exactly true see if you
actually go to the blockchain explorer
and go to blockchain uh
block zero what you actually find out is
that this man was being a bit deceitful
see the truth is the total pre-mine
was actually 8 million bitcloud that is
equal to 42
of the total supply of big clout that
will ever exist
hey it's been pre-mined meaning you
don't have access
to it where did that money go where oh
where did it go well
it is true that 2.3 million went to the
founders but we don't know where the
other 5.7 million big clout went
but quickly i realized this whole thing
was set up to benefit
everyone who were in early investors and
uh screw over
anyone who got in late right this is not
a project that's built to last this is a
project that's built to
benefit the people who got in early so
as part of the pre-mine i ended up
cross-referencing all the public
you know keys with big clouds blockchain
explorer whatever it doesn't matter i
did it
anyway this is what we found these are
all the users who got bitclout
from the genesis block meaning they
didn't do anything they didn't
pay for it they just got it credited to
their their account
now if you notice our big boy chamath at
the current price of bitcloud
has 15 million dollars credited some
people attach their real names to it
some people don't the point is is that
these are the names
that got publicly credited with bitcloud
but these names will come back later now
of course this
valuation is kind of silly right now
because of course um you can't get
bitclout
over to bitcoin this is just
theoretically how much money they have
so that's the first part of the scheme
summarized investors got paid out
huge sums of bitcloud and a total of 42
of all existing bitcoin big cloud excuse
me that will ever exist
already has been minted or pre-mined if
you will now for this next part i want
to refer to our good old boy gin
and juice here snoop dogg should i claim
my big cloud he asked on
april 7th and somebody responds ye bro
buys your bit clout first jump on the
join clubhouse and i'll explain
otherwise everyone will benefit from
your coin and pump the value
this is the stupid growth hack that big
clout has put people in is
people look at big cloud they go whoa i
got huge sums of money
all these big celebrities they say hey i
have huge sums of money in big cloud i
should go
claim it i look it's free money right
this
is part of the scheme because when snoop
dogg goes to his profile he sees that he
has 41 coins
were 375 000
that's really interesting who doesn't
want almost half a million dollars
for doing absolutely nothing but the
only problem is where is this money
coming from well this is where
a guy named crypto comes in he's done an
incredible thread i'll link it in the
description below on this whole
scheme and it blew my mind bitclout is
artificially pumping
reserved creator profiles to make it
look like they're really valuable
in order for legit creators to come in
there by endorsing bitcloud to get big
clout you have to tweet about it
so you have to endorse bitcloud that
gets your followers to think big cloud
is a legitimate endeavor
that they should go put their money in
by the way you can't get your money out
which then
uh sort of legitimizes the whole project
so how are they artificially pumping
these things well on march 11th they
started sending bitclout to all the
profiles that were
were reserved not like the investors
right and they had the profiles
automatically buy up their own coin see
if you notice
bit snoop dogg already holds his own
coin despite
not having joined the platform at all
not having set a founder reward nothing
so how did this happen
well they were sent bitclout by these
two genesis public keys okay
remember the genesis block there were uh
i think 482
genesis keys that were given these eight
million bit clout that no one knows
where they are who they're two et cetera
now one profile
named master specifically was in his job
was basically to send
uh bitclout to these starter profiles
these profiles they stall
pump up the value artificially so that
these creators think to themselves
maybe i should go maybe i should go
claim that now remember in the genesis
block
master got a hundred thousand bit clout
so that's how he did it
now when snoop dogg goes on his profile
he thinks
that there's legitimate interest in his
profile when in reality
this is minted pre-mined coins that are
essentially
worthless right they're not worth
anything it cost absolutely
zero dollars to make him now this gets
more insidious when you look at profiles
even bigger like justin bieber one of
the biggest profiles
on big cloud now big clout would get a
lot of credibility by him joining right
so rather than go about this the
official way and
you know prove that their their
company's valuable and prove that they
have
real legitimacy well first what do they
do well they pre-give justin bieber a
bunch of coins so his
valuation just gets pumped up they just
throw 40 coins at a creator just so they
like pump up his value right away
then they have people like fallows
invest
13 coins he's from the genesis block and
he's one of the main holders
of justin bieber coin guess who else is
happy penguin
happy penguin is also one of the genesis
block
guys with elon musk it's the same story
it's a bunch of anonymous accounts i
wonder who those could be i wonder if
they're the
hundreds of anonymous accounts who
haven't moved their genesis block
uh you also have the talent fund who uh
incidentally yeah right there
one of the other largest holders is arts
is arts one of the guys
oh why yes he's one of the top 10 most
rewarded
bit clout holders right the genesis
block now what does this mean
well it means when people like snoop
dogg are asking should i claim my big
clout and people say well yeah it's
free money it's really not it's just
invented money
that they pre-mined pumped up your
valuation gave you a bunch of fake coins
that
uh they also i guess pre-mined i guess
the whole
thing is like to pressure you to join
they're just throwing away money
now you might say well i don't know it's
a growth hack strategy
whatever but there's an important
problem this lures in
legitimate investors who think these
crazy valuations are due to
actual demand who will then throw real
money
after fake bunk this is the whole
beautiful thing about crypto you know
back in the day when people launched a
company
who guess who took the risk the founder
the founder didn't cash out until an ipo
there's some kind of an exit event but
until then they're taking
all the risk crypto some of these
projects have managed to figure out how
to put all the risk
on you the guy diamond hands or nader
theory as we think he is
does he take a loss the creator no he
walks away with a
200 million dollar bag after failing
what happens to your money because
you're expected to pay in
buy in with real bitcoin so even if it
fails
you take the laws not the founders right
and the point is they're no worse for
the where yeah maybe you lost some money
but did they
so let's just try to run back a brief
conclusion of this whole platform this
whole
social media experiment that says it's
just
coins and code remember from the white
paper guys last episode it's just
coins and code here's how it worked they
got a bunch of famous people
who are kind of known in the investing
crypto space i don't know how they got
them involved
i don't know how much these people knew
ahead of time full disclosure they could
have had no idea what was going on they
could have had a lot of idea
okay uh but they go hey you want to be
involved in this thing we'll give you a
huge chunk of um
the currency and we'll pre-mine 42
of it we're not going to tell anybody
what we're going to do with that then
what we're going to we're going to take
all the popular creators on twitter
we're going to steal their identity
upload them our
them to our platform preload them with a
bunch of fake money
and we're going to artificially set
their creator value
at like this huge inflated price so that
when these people go look they go wow
this is a big platform with a lot of
creators
by the way a lot of the genesis mining
guys you tell them hey why don't you go
invest some of that
invest some of that in the creators
before anyone else has access so they
get access to all the top creators
before you do
thereby running up the price now this is
all before you ever see anything
then you get introduced to the the thing
by saying wow guys hey
look tyler and cameron winklevoss the
winkle twins
they're involved guys who's ever heard
of them losing out on anything
let's all dive into that not knowing
their way to make money is this thing
being valuable meanwhile
journalists are writing articles about
how a mysterious influence or stock
market is worth
one billion dollars i don't know a few
like a month after launch really a
billion dollars that's what you think
this thing's worth
i think it's worth the exact amount the
last idiot puts into it but even apart
from the scam
think about what if it actually works
what if they actually become the next
twitter as they say
uh they want to be i mean right like
they want to be the crypto social
network do you know the insane
fees they're going to be that are going
to be charged per tweet because as you
know you have to pay
fees for all this stuff right when you
tweet or re-cloud
when you cloud or i don't know what they
call it uh you have to pay
and as the price of these fees goes up
what do you think the regular people who
are supposed to make up the main body of
this thing are gonna do
do you think you're gonna wanna pay a
dollar to tweet i don't think so
and i think the final future of this
project can be best summarized by this
guy named chamath
uh he talks about growing a business too
fast and how it leads to destruction
so here's my little theory about company
value creation
the faster you build it that is the
half-life it will get destroyed in the
same amount of time and so when you
think about a lot of like
social businesses that's played out but
and when you see sort of like
what the sort of like the top so like
you know does it take
eight nine ten years to build a really
great consumer business
it'll take eight nine ten twelve years
to destroy it um
and we may see the tipping point a
couple of these businesses right now we
may be seeing it in front of our eyes
well said chermoth it took about a month
and a half two months
big cloud exploded into a one billion
dollar business seemingly overnight i
wonder how long it'll take for this
thing to collapse
no matter what all the people who are
profiting off this site want to tell you
this is not gonna be the future of
twitter people are not going to want to
pay
bitclout to go tweet and you'll be
knowing the full time
that basically you gave the bag to
people who
already have the bag i mean i don't know
what to tell you i mean honestly you
almost have to admire
the architecture of this whole thing
it's built perfectly to capitalize
on people's fomo and greed but uh will
it work in the long run
i don't think so i think this team has
demonstrated a pattern of
lies and deception and what people are
saying is genius marketing which just
basically amounts to breaking
publicity like right to publicity laws
yeah breaking the law
cool strat guys let's see how that works
out for you anyways
that's my follow-up hope you enjoyed
nobody's covering this thing dude i i
can't imagine why
all right well that's it see you guys
next time i know what you need
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost
wake up and smell me coffee